want to give a shout out to our good
friend uh joe biden over here because
he's got this tweet that just went up
today he said we need congress to pass
universal background checks that's
insane because they already exist ban
assault weapons and high-capacity
magazines assault weapon doesn't mean
anything and he wants to ban 100 round
magazines or i guess that would be a
drum wow
and eliminate gun manufacturers immunity
from liability these are insane these
are insane statements let me just let me
just be totally real first when you go
buy a gun you got even in a
constitutional carry state you've got
the knicks system nics no was it
national instant uh criminal check
system or something like that you uh or
check system you walk in you say i wanna
buy the gun you gotta fill out your form
they say give us a minute and then
sometimes they'll be like you're delayed
have a nice day you can't buy the gun
because universal background checks
already exist you see what he's trying
to say is if you live in the mountains
of west virginia and you want to sell a
gun to your neighbor who also lives in
the mountains of west virginia he wants
you to be forced to drive to a local gun
store ffl federally licensed and do the
transfer that way personally i think
you're usually better off doing that but
i understand why you want to give your
neighbor a weapon because you live in
the middle of nowhere and there's wild
animals or you need to defend yourself
in your property and there's no police
it makes sense that's what he's saying
banning assault weapons is meaningless
because what they're talking about is
like it's a pistol grip versus a rifle
grip and it's just meaningless high
capacity magazines
when you buy an ar
how many rounds the magazine typically
hold 30. 30 rounds that's standard but
they're saying high capacity
anything more than 10
but when you literally buy the weapon
it's a 30 round magazine when you go on
the shelf all 30. you want a 10 round
mech i guess you can get one if you want
to make one but this is what they're
trying to do they're trying to reduce
the standard capacity eliminate gun
manufacturers immunity from liability
now that's just insane making a weapon
and then you get sued for what someone
else does okay all right let's eliminate
all car manufacturers liabilities yeah
i'm just going to say or knife
manufacturers right someone gets stabbed
with your product you go to court buddy
can't come after pfizer yeah that's it
that's the liability
you go after remington but you can't go
after fives or modern pharmaceuticals
should not in my opinion have liability
i think that if someone takes a vaccine
from a company and gets really sick that
there's a court that will protect these
things is ridiculous these companies
like they feel like they really i
understand they're saying they shouldn't
have liability i think that they should
be able to be sued no i don't think they
should be immune from damaging people
with their medicines or with their drugs
or whatever you want to call them well
i agree there's challenges in that
there's going to be side effects for
basically everything and you know you
might be allergic to something and not
know or you might be the the one in
whatever manny if so like let's say you
get like some kind of uh swelling
treatment and they're like there's a
rare side effect it gives you rash you
get a rash yeah i think top-down
medicine production isn't the way of the
future a lot of it's like we're gonna
start 3d printing medicine that's
tailor-made for your chemistry your body
chemistry and uh so this whole top-down
medicine where they make one drug and
give it to everyone is obviously not
working because a lot of people aren't
doing well with it so i have a story
about nancy pelosi asking me about guns
in the backyard uh in beverly hills i
really like to hear it absolutely i know
right that guy even that your attention
yeah let's hear it so i'm back there i
got invited to sing at tony bennett's
85th birthday party
and i'm in the backyard of ted sarandos
the founder of netflix i'm in his
backyard there's john travolta queen
latifah and i are bringing out the
birthday cake i mean you can't make this
up i'm looking around this backyard
going
i'm not supposed to be here so i'm just
gonna have some fun you know like mine
no one of these things is not like the
other so i'm back there and i'm hanging
out and and i see nancy pelosi over
there starts making a beeline towards me
and i'll be honest it was frightening it
was frightening
she's coming and she walks right up to
me she doesn't say hello she goes you
seem like a reasonable person uh
i guess meaning for a guy in a cowboy
hat and a handlebar mustache because
otherwise you wouldn't be at this
backyard right you must be a reasonable
you seem like a reasonable person i said
well i appreciate that madam speaker she
goes can i ask you a question about guns
oh
i said absolutely oh yeah so vince
vaughn is standing there and vince leans
in travolta's got his arms crossed
everybody's leaning in
and uh uh
pelosi goes now i'm not a hunter but i'm
pretty sure
that if i shot that first bullet at
whatever i was hunting and i didn't hit
it it would run away i go that's correct
she goes so why does anybody need more
than seven rounds is what she said why
does he might need more than seven
rounds
in their gun
and i held up my cell phone i said well
madam speaker right now back in
nashville tennessee i have a wife and i
got a three-year-old son and a
five-year-old son and we live right in
the middle of town
i said now she called my phone right now
and said john i hear footsteps coming up
the stairs i said madam speaker would
you advise me to tell my wife to grab
the one with seven rounds or the one
with 30 rounds
and her eyes kind of got big and she
said
is that the way you look at that
i said yes ma'am she goes
well it was nice to meet you and then
just walked off but for a brief moment
this light bulb pops i believe first of
all they know that anyway that's why
they all have armed guards yeah yep but
i was able to dead in her eye one time
say it's to protect our families of
course we need 30 rounds to hunt a deer
and there's nothing in the second
amendment about hunting it's all about
defense good for you how many rounds
does that they're armed guards
right that what kind of guns yes i was
just going to ask they're going to have
17 plus ones they're going to have 21
plus ones they're going to have high
capacity they're going to have multiple
high capacity clips on their belts
because if something breaks out they're
in a gunfight oh and and i think uh when
it comes to the speaker she's probably
got a couple guys with short barreled
rifles no doubt about it no doubt about
it so
you can confront them and i would always
advise anybody if you're ever talking to
your neighbors friends about gun about
guns and clips and whatever
is that
you have the right to defend your family
how you see fit you don't get to tell me
how i get to defend my family those are
my kids that is my wife god put me in
charge of them in charge of their
defense and if something happens to them
that's on me
and i'd rather deal with your bad
opinion of my high-capacity gun than
deal with a dead child or a dead family
we already got a couple people saying
clips
magazines uh-oh but what's that magazine
it's that mentality that allowed us to
build this country the way we did if we
were all getting picked off at home
and the government had total control and
they weren't afraid of the population we
never would have had this beautiful
liberal society that we organized sorry
to use the word liberal i'm bringing it
back to what it really means which is
liberty sure um no i mean look the
founders make it perfectly clear in the
founding documents of this country that
owning a gun is a right that is
available to all people it is not a
privilege for the ultra wealthy who can
afford our armed guards and whatever
paperwork these bureaucrats would try to
put you through in order to be able to
defend yourself but now now john would
you agree with me when i say the second
amendment guarantees our right to have
nuclear weapons and biological weapons
uh-oh no i didn't see that in there no i
do i see it in there do you yeah so i
got in trouble because i i pointed that
out and
they they take this clip of me where
they cut my false statement and say tim
poole calls for people to have nuclear
and biological weapons what i said was
the constitution says the right to keep
and bear arms it doesn't specify
what right and back then as a privateer
as a private citizen you could have any
weapon the government could have correct
that hasn't changed they wanted equal
force right yeah has that changed
well well we yeah we now cannot get our
hands on weapons that are equal force
but the second amendment didn't change
they just started passing laws correct
without
any uh
i guess legitimate questions as to what
the limits should have actually been and
this is what joe biden is doing now now
i i would not want people to have
nuclear weapons or uh biological weapons
that's scary thought some lunatic guy
with a bioweapon because of how much
destruction could be wrought but there's
a very serious question about
when do we draw that line and say
regardless of the constitutional
amendments we've decided you can't have
things
you'd have to amend the constitution to
change that that's a good argument well
i think i think we could easily amend it
to be like yeah we we've decided nuclear
weapons and buy weapons like we're not
going to include in the second amendment
right yeah let's take that off the table
well i think there's also another
serious question to ask which is why did
biden just decide recently that this was
going to be his next moral crusade the
country's falling apart we have runaway
inflation he's acknowledged food
shortages are coming and he's going to
sit here and tell us that his goal is
that is the end gun violence it's
because he thinks there's going to be
gun violence if there's famine
and wants to try and stop it by taking
the guns away so there's criminal gangs
running around creating mafia like what
the heck i'll push back a little bit
i mean it may just be he needs a
distraction it could be so you know in
response to biden jeffrey miller said oh
look a new emotionally vivid issue to
distract us from inflation and your
catastrophic monetary policy yep so
yeah they've been blaming inflation on
putin i don't know something i thought
was true for a long time that i found
out was not true and i wonder how many
gun owners think this is true uh i'm
friends with the guy it's been the atf
29 years uh and we were hanging out on a
little vacation together and he was kind
of bumming around and uh they were
trying to it was another one of these
gun bills we're trying to get past
and i said man you know they ever come
door to door want to take people's guns
i said the atf right they got he goes
john
people don't know what guns you own the
government doesn't know what guns you
own i said what are you talking about
he said there is no gun registry for the
united states of america he said here's
how a crime works i go to a crime scene
there's a colt pistol laying in the
street we have to get the colt pistol we
have to call colt the manufacturer find
out who they sold the gun to what store
they originally sold the gun to it could
be a 30 year old weapon
if the store still exists and if they
still have records going back that far
we can find out who purchased the gun
originally then we have to go find that
person and if that person no longer owns
the gun we have to see if they have any
records of who they sold it to and on
and on and on he said we would have to
do that with literally every single
weapon in the united states to know
who's got what guns so this is just like
a fear tactic they want people to think
that they know who has they don't know
they do not know now in illinois
california new york they have state gun
registries in those states and he said
those are the only three where they
actually know what guns you own yeah
which one the past 15 20 years
california new york and illinois that's
why the gun crime's so low that yeah
right i was going to say like there's
something interesting about those states
was as it pertains to their gun laws
they also have a whole lot of gun crime
yeah well you know look baltimore's got
serious gun crime as well it's not just
those states but when i hear illinois
i'm like they call it chiraq because of
how many gun deaths there are more you
know there was like a year where there
were more gun deaths in chicago than the
entirety of iraq
yeah and their laws don't seem to do
anything to stop that granted uh i think
it was in 2000's there was a court
ruling that i think the supreme court
ruling so now you can actually get a gun
in illinois though it's damn near
impossible
yeah
i just found that to be isn't that a
myth though yeah didn't you think that
was probably for sure if they just
they'll show up and go mr rich we see
that you own xyz he goes we have no idea
what you want yeah in the movies they're
like we got the gun we got the serial
number we're going to run it through the
registry and they're like oh we got
there's a registry now when i see tweets
like that from biden he's talking about
universal background checks if he said
universal
registry
that's a different animal that's a
different thing if you ever see the word
registry the background check is
probably the registry yeah that's
exactly the plan that's that's probably
the way they would work it in the bill
would actually turn into a registry i
find that we're on the verge of 3d
printed guns like the 21st century is
going to be all about crafting your own
weaponry and stuff i verge of yeah we're
in it it has begun the ghost gun is a
real product we have but the go the
ghost gun is you just making your weapon
control pew we've had on the show
posting all these videos on twitter of
the guns they just make yeah how
effective were those at this point i
remember seeing some early prototypes
and they were pretty lousy really yup
yeah the early ones they had to pull the
hammer with a straight they pulled the
trigger with a string from like eight
feet back so it didn't explode in their
hand because they didn't know they were
plastic they'd fall apart they fire one
bullet at a time but the new ones are
there was the first one you remember
what was called
i don't know the liberator sort of the
little the little white plastic handgun
that was good for like five shots or
something but no one one shot
now if you if you go on twitter and you
follow control pew and you look at the
url yeah ctrl pew and you look at all
the things they're posting
yo
they have unique designs and these
things work it's just it's it's no
longer like the old days they've figured
this stuff out it's like a whack-a-mole
i could see a totalitarian regime would
use that as a game of whack-a-mole to
just write more and more laws of how to
go after more and more gunman's like
dude at some point like you're stepping
on your own foot it you know we're
working together here
there's real problems out there and it
comes down to do you have enough water
and do you have enough food and you have
enough space to move around
decentralization has done wonders yeah
with the internet one of the things
that's pushing back on the the
establishment cult woke nonsense is that
people who live in rural areas now have
the ability to uh to build community it
used to be that the message the
narrative would come top down from big
cities with big city intellectuals and
that was it community was formed around
their broadcast tower but now because of
the internet people can build their own
communities which is a lot which is
allowing more conservatives to you know
coalesce around certain personalities
certain media outlets
you have the same thing with 3d printing
they can't they can't stop it thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you